et cet incendie dramatique jettent une
lumière crue sur les immeubles
insalubres au selon la mairie de paris
ils sont une centaine délaissés par
leurs propriétaires et souvent squatté
dans des conditions extrêmement
précaires gens payent eux il y aurait de
300 à 500 logements insalubres à paris
une centaine d'immeubles selon la mairie
la majorité sont occupés par des
familles étrangères avec comme dans
l'immeuble du 10e arrondissement qui a
brûlé à grand nombre d'enfants
la difficulté pour traiter le problème
des logements insalubres tient à ce que
leurs propriétaires des personnes
privées les laisse souvent à l'abandon
des pouvoirs publics de par la loi
doivent intervenir mais la ville de
paris et la préfecture laquelle dépend
de l'état n'arrive pas toujours agir
ensemble
après beaucoup de tergiversations avec
l'état le conseil de paris le 20 octobre
à voter un texte qui permet à la mairie
d'acquérir les immeubles dangereux afin
de démolir et de reloger ses occupants
l'immeuble du 10e arrondissement et dans
ce cas l'ennui est que la préfecture
doit prendre une déclaration d'utilité
publique pour que la démolition et leur
logement soit possible une opération qui
dure des mois
c'est pourquoi une association comme
droit au logement demande à ce qu on
réquisitionne des logements vides
c'est ce qu'avait fait le ministre
socialiste marie noëlle lienemann puis
le rpr pierre andré périssol quelques
centaines de logements avaient ainsi été
attribués aux mal logés